the chest
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his tonic and gin
he says son can you play me a memory
i'm not really sure how it goes
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it complete
when i was
[Music]
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
now
[Music]
me
[Music]
always
he's a macho man
oh
body baby
[Music]
has
hey
all right
all right
uh
oh
a special
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so many times it happens too fast
don't lose your grip on the dreams of
the past
you must fight just to keep them alive
[Music]
please please please
please
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
[Music]
got me wrong
[Music]
please
[Music]
me
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i wanna be a man
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
i've had
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
cause we are the champions
of
[Music]
rosie
i consider it a challenge
is
we are
my friends
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
i love this land
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time
[Music]
i know i'm free
[Music]
i love this land
[Music]
[Music]
next to you and defend her still
[Music]
today
ah thank you very much thank you
thank you fayetteville and north
carolina thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
tomorrow we are going to win this state
and we are going to win
four more years in our great
white house with your vote we will
continue to cut your taxes
cut regulations support our great police
support our fantastic military
care for our veterans protect your
second amendment
defend religious liberty and ensure more
products are proudly stamped with that
wonderful phrase
made in the usa
next year will be the greatest economic
year in the history of our country
under my leadership our economy is now
growing at the fastest rate ever
recorded
33.1 just announced
last week we created a record 11.4
million jobs in the last
five months it's a a number that we
never even thought possible nobody did
nobody thought it was possible
and we're going to now even do better
than that it's going very rapidly
while foreign nations are in a free fall
you see what's going on with so many
nations in europe unfortunately
i say that with sadness we are creating
an economic powerhouse unrivaled
anywhere in the world
a recent gallup poll found that 56 of
americans say they are better off today
than they were four years ago under
obama and biden
you gotta remember that so you gotta
remember that kind of thing
they didn't do a good job in fact if
they did i wouldn't have run
if they did i wouldn't be here right now
they did a bad job and obama
uh he went out yesterday with biden they
got like 14 people they didn't have too
many
they didn't have too good a crowd and
we have five of these today five
we have some big ones thank you
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
thank you thank you very much
thank you and i love you too and i
appreciate that
we appreciate it
i was i was thinking coming in because i
watched these fake polls everyone no
matter
if we're up by 10 if we know we're going
to win
easily he's down by one point he's down
by one
uh i just watched his fake stuff and i
was saying to myself you know
we've been under a phony fake
hoax investigation for three years
nothing but bad and really
corrupt publicity from these people
and i say i wonder what the difference
would have been
had it been legit right had it been
legit and it turned out to be just the
opposite
they were the ones that committed the
crimes not us
but i wonder what it would have been i
probably would have been a little bit
easier but you know the good news we're
going to win anyway we're going to
shove it we're going to win anyway i
wonder what it would have been
i wonder what it would have been if all
of the nonsense wasn't brought up
thank you very thank you very much
looking tremendous in florida so of
course they don't mention that
you know it's florida okay we are
looking good we're really looking good
all over in the real polls not the fox
polls those fox balls
somebody in fox doesn't like me very
much i can tell you
they are the phoniest paul so they were
they were almost as bad
four years ago actually there were worse
but you get some of these pollsters
they work magic and the amazing thing is
and they they hang on to their jobs they
do horribly
look at what they did last i had nine
states
and i had to win them all and they said
i was going to lose all nine
this is four years ago i was gonna lose
all nine it's gonna be a very short
evening for donald trump
and depaul said decisively i was gonna
lose all nine
and that was the day before and i won
all nine
i want no i won or i wouldn't be here
right now
no i won all nine and said we're gonna
lose all nine
and it was quite depressing as i turned
on the television let's see how we did
he won
florida he won south carolina
and then they said they're getting rid
of the guy like at fox i heard they were
getting rid of that pulsar and they kept
him
and they have others they kept and you
wonder what kind of a business that is
you wonder what guy
we have a case where in wisconsin i have
we're one up and i left there a couple
of days ago we had a rally you wouldn't
believe it
packed just packed just like last night
like here but
like last night this was the section you
know i wanted to come this is considered
a small
beautiful cute little wonderful section
and they asked me and i said i want to
be there no and every vote counts it's
very important
we had something last night in miami you
would not have believed it i don't know
who saw it on television
i don't know but you
you look at some of these uh results in
wisconsin
so you know whether i'm up one or down
one
it's right in that thing i think we're
going to win wisconsin because
we have a lot of people that say we
don't want to talk to you and then they
go vote for trump right you know
the hidden voter or whatever they call
them somebody said they're the shy
voters
my people are not shy
but in wisconsin so they said abc
news which is in my opinion corrupt but
they're all corrupt abc news washington
post
which is basically a uh uh
lobbyist as far as i'm concerned for
amazon
it's just a lobbyist so they didn't say
like he's two down three down four down
a fake poll
they said trump is 17 points down in
wisconsin
now the real number i mean you know i
could lose it i could win it i think
it's
you know i don't know how i'm not i did
a lot of good things for wisconsin but
you know let's say it's even and i call
up a great pollster
john i said john let me ask you a
question
i think we're one up in wisconsin but
abc washington post they did the same
thing
four years ago if you remember that very
close to the election
they said we're down 12. and then we won
right but we were down 12.
and it's disheartening it's called
suppression what it does is it
suppresses people they say well listen
we love the president but if he can't
win
so abc but they did it four years ago
and we complained bitterly with a very
good lawyer
i had very good lawyers in those days we
complained very bitterly
and they changed it right before the
election i think it was one
right we're down one they took it from
twelve to one and it's like
about 15 seconds and i realized i said
this is a phony business
but now they come down and it says 17
down in wisconsin
17. so i called john john mclaughlin
he's like the dean he's a great guy and
he's been very good with me
i mean he said we're going to win four
years ago he said he said we're going to
win easily
this one he's he's probably the biggest
and the best
i said john let me ask you a question
abc washington post came out with a poll
it said i was 17 down i'm not 17 down
i might be one down or i might be two up
but i'm not 17 down
what's going on why don't they make it
because they have to live after that
they have to do other events another
why don't they make it three or four or
two or five
or something right he said they can't do
that because they want you to lose
and if you're two or three or four
everyone's going to go vote
they want to make sure that your people
don't vote
and when you're 17 down people say i
just can't waste my time i'm not going
to stand online
and i said isn't that sick and he said
he knows some of the people
and they're very smart they're very
brilliant they're smart people
he said but if they made it five down or
four down or six down even
so they make it something that's so bad
17 down i said isn't that a shame i want
to tell that story do you mind he said i
don't care that's the way it is
so it's crooked stuff the fox polls are
horrible every time i have a fox poll
it's horrible i mean i like some of the
things on fox certainly sean
and laura and tucker's been great lately
and fox and friends in the morning is
great right
we go through them we have we have some
i find harris to be great harris
faulkner to be really good
she's been very good over a period of
time the great lou dobbs he's been
fantastic right
right janine how do you like your name
and you know look we have some uh we
have some great people that support us
jesse has been great people has been
and i don't want to mention you know
there are a lot of people look we have a
lot but it's 90
negative everything you know everything
it's that but so think of that
so i said 17 and he gave me an answer i
just thought it was so incredible i said
i got to tell that answer so i hope i
haven't bored you but
i thought it was interesting
i thought it was a justin to me it was
interesting and
and you know i have like uh five of
these to do today so let's get going
and i appreciate you being here we had
some
we had some monsters last night we had
some little rough weather it wasn't like
this
we had uh in michigan we had a slightly
cold day with the wind blowing at 40
miles an hour in my face
and you're lucky you have a president
that doesn't need a teleprompter i was
able to
good memory
i would have been in big trouble there
was no way you could hold paper there
was no way you could do where you were
just
and my guys set it up where the wind was
right smack in my face
and i was looking at that flag from the
play and i said oh no here we go again
but actually the flag must be a very
high quality silk
because it's not that windy but
yesterday it was not
that was not an easy day we had some
very cold stops say biden and harris
kamala
kamala you want her you want her as your
first woman president i don't think so
and the radical left gain power they
will collapse our economy and send our
nation into a depression
biden will raise your taxes four
trillion dollars
massively increase your regulations
close down your factories send your jobs
overseas that's what he's been doing all
his life
him and his group destroy the suburbs
dissolve your borders
terminate religious liberty outlaw
private health insurance 180 million
people have great health insurance
shred your second amendment confiscate
your guns and indoctrinate your children
with anti-american lies
biden has vowed to abolish the american
oil and natural gas
industries and van fracking he said for
a year and a half
he said it then all of a sudden he goes
to pennsylvania no i never said that
and the fake news doesn't do anything
about it
baden's energy ban will send every state
into crushing poverty from north
carolina to michigan to pennsylvania
as long as i'm president we will remain
the number one producer of oil and
natural gas on earth
and we will remain energy independent
sleepy joe biden is a globalist who
spent 47 years
outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders and sacrificing american blood
and treasure in
endless foreign wars in countries that
most of you have never even heard of
he was a cheerleader for nafta and
they're all coming home don't worry
about it
i said it
[Applause]
he was a cheerleader for nafta and
china's entry into the world trade
organization
north carolina lost 50 percent of all
manufacturing jobs after those biden
betrayals
and now he says oh i'm going to she's
trying to follow my policy
he's trying to follow my policy he's not
going to do my policy he's been doing
this for
47 years plus and for eight years as
vice president which was only three and
a half years ago
joe biden is a corrupt politician who
raked in millions from china while
giving them
your jobs
he's a corrupt he's a corrupt politician
you see it
now they say the laptop chef watermelon
head
[ __ ] that laptop was produced by
russia here we go again russia russia
russia
here we go again can you imagine what
they must think of and
these people are crazy now i was
it was produced by where's hunter that's
right it was produced by
these guys are really thinking of it now
schiff knows he said you know psycho in
many ways but he knows
it's a total con game i had to put up
with it for three years
and it affects it you know when you see
nothing but negative television
every night every night every night
and then they find totally no collusion
after wasting 48 million dollars
18 people think of it and then it's no
collusion but then you have to run but
you've had three years of horrible
publicity
and they did it i mean they did it they
were the criminals hillary was a
criminal
she deleted her emails people go to jail
for that
these are criminals these are criminals
and say it any way you want to do it
but we took the brunt that we caught him
spying on my campaign and trying to
overthrow a
duly elected president of the united
states
so i go and that was before i even knew
i mean that was while i was
while i was running i didn't even know
i'd hear these things sir
uh this is before i got elected guys
would come up to me every once in a
while
sir do you have anything to do with
russia
i said no why do you ask oh i was just
curious
because it was like this thing floating
around then they come up again
sir are you sure you don't have anything
to do with russia i said i have nothing
to do with russia what the hell are you
talking about
and you know you hear it four or five
times then you get into office and they
come up with this scheme
and this this plot there's a plot to
overthrow the government to the united
states
and then we have people that just don't
act as i mean it's just unbelievable
we have so much we have so much
information
we have so much we have the whole thing
and obama was involved
and biden was involved
they were involved but yes let's let's
see what happens
people should move more quickly in 2016
north carolina voted to fire this
corrupt political establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting america first
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician it's because i'm
not a politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment it's
because i was elected to fight for you
and i fight harder than any
president has ever fought for his people
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
get out and vote that's all i ask just
take a little time and vote
wow we got to win this state i think we
win this state we win pennsylvania
we're going to win florida we win
pennsylvania and you
we're going to win the whole thing
[Music]
and we'll send them a signal like
they've never seen before this has not
happened to them big tech is so powerful
you can't beat big tech they're saying
this and i see it on twitter
trending trending trend right it's not
trending they put the most boring thing
only it was anything bad about me number
one in the world on trend right
boring stuff i mean like stuff as
opposed to
affairs scandals that they don't even
put that stuff up
it's always trump two three four five
items
it's a fix it's a fix this is a
smart guy we have his name everybody
knows who he is
and i'm not talking about the primary
i'm talking about people that work
they take stuff out of my head let's see
this is bad about trump
let's make it worse okay we'll make it
worse okay number one
trend in the whole world no that's not
stuff that trends but these are phony
guys
they fix the elections and you know what
they should be
subject to campaign violations because
it's they're
uh
they're in arm of the democrat national
committee they work together
they work on messaging together the
democrats
the fake news media they're the worst
the fact that they're fake
people and if i've done one thing it's
to expose the dishonesty in the media
and not everybody but a big vast
majority a vast majority
not everybody look at us we catch hunter
and joe cheating we catch them stealing
millions of dollars
they refuse to write a story could you
imagine if i
got three and a half million dollars
from the mayor
of moscow's wife could you imagine
somebody gave me three and a half
million bucks
somebody gave me 20 i got they impeached
me because i made a perfect phone call
to the head of ukraine i never met the
gentleman congratulations on your win
if you see anything corrupt please call
the attorney general of the united
states
and we have a corruption agreement with
them because it's been a very corrupt
country
i actually have an obligation now of
course they
impeached before they found out before i
decided to release the phone call
isn't it lucky that i had that call
transcribed
new magic
can you imagine now they couldn't do
they didn't know what to do crazy nancy
said this is an
impeachable she said you're right they
said
you're right but let's go through with
it anyway
maybe we'll get lucky can you no this is
what because she didn't know about the
call
when she read the call she said he
didn't do anything wrong
how did you get me into this you shifty
shift
how did you do it
[Music]
jerry nadler i've been fighting this guy
for 25 years on the east side of
manhattan the west side of manhattan
jerry nadler he's a beauty isn't he
how did he get me into this well let's
just keep going forward
it's a disgrace everyone i will say this
for the republicans
197 or 697
to nothing we won and in the senate
52 and a half to one half we lost a half
of it i wonder who that could have been
but sleepy joe biden is bought and paid
for
by china he's got hey they gave the son
a billion and a half dollars to manage
that means he's gonna make millions of
dollars a year he doesn't know anything
about investment
didn't know anything at all about energy
got a hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars a month
on energy think of that think of that
hundred and eighty thousand dollars
i called a friend of mine on wall street
is this a normal fee
he said no it may be the most abnormal
fee i've ever seen in my whole life i've
been doing this for 25 years he's the
biggest guy
but they're bought and paid for they got
the money and then they were going for
the big one in china they wrote a letter
to
a very big powerful man within the
communist party
and where's hunter as for 10
million dollars a year as he was going
to recommend
he was going to talk you're going to see
here's a guy didn't have a job got
thrown out of the navy
he got thrown out of the navy he didn't
have a job
biden becomes vice president and
this kid is like a vacuum cleaner going
all over the world
following his father picking up the
scraps you know he's following his dad
picking up scraps
and then you find the note where the big
man gets ten percent the big
men's joe bye the big man gets ten then
in one case they said fifty percent
right that's more likely
because he wouldn't do it for ten he'd
want because these people are all
hangers on
losers but uh that's the story
and it's in a laptop and now they say
the laptop was made by russia therefore
it has no credibility
can you no no can you believe this all
right
and so the news is not outside of the
new york post which really
i hold in high esteem they have done
they're like
a hero paper
and they endorsed me i got a nice
endorsement from
did you see from pennsylvania yesterday
right pittsburgh pittsburgh gazette
that was nice once i got through that
first paragraph
it was phenomenal actually they said we
don't love his personality we don't love
his tough
but i have to be tough look i've been
under investigation
from before i ever became president i
have to be tough if i was soft
i wouldn't be here right now and they
don't want to say that
i was under a fake investigation by a
lot of fake people
bob mueller and his crew the whole thing
was a fake scam
that should have never been started and
they knew the answer on the first day
but it took them two and a half years to
put it down no collusion
but they knew the answer the first day
so i was under investigation
for the first two and a half years right
think of that
and then they say he's tough but i'll
take it anyway i'll take your
endorsement anyway
because once you get over the first
paragraph or two
it says all of the things we've done
which are incredible
which are incredible
and now i'll have a chance to do it uh
without the cloud because i had a cloud
hanging over my head whether we like it
or not
and then they say he was tough he fought
too hard
he was somewhat crude he was very very
nasty
his twitter now you know what if i
didn't have social media i wouldn't be
here was the only way i could defend
myself
so it's one of those things but i just
wonder i was thinking i asked the people
on the way up we have great people such
loyal great people
including a man that comes from an area
not too far from here is a good friend
of these women who've been here six this
is number
64 time for these incredible beautiful
i think rich women and their husbands
are in here some place
but they had their husbands they were at
the one last night that was a big deal
wasn't it
but uh this is number 64 i would say
right
65 oh there's two more they come from
north carolina but we have mark meadows
comes from north carolina
[Applause]
and he has been fantastic he's done a
great job
he's done a great job where is he he's
probably working you know he's bum bum
bum with a phone he's got two phones
instead of one
and he's not going to break it up with a
hammer like hillary did he's going to
it's going to throw it away
he'll come down what he's done a
fantastic job
and he is and he loves this state he
loves north carolina
and i specifically said i want somebody
from north carolina and give me meadows
now i knew three years ago i said we got
to get meadows in here big tech
big media big donors and powerful
special interests
are desperate for sleepy jill
to win they want them to win i'll tell
you who wants them to win china
they will own our country because they
own him they control him and they know
he will always be there to do their
bidding he'll always be there it's a
corrupt
he's a corrupt politician i don't care
i'll say and i say it everybody knows
it's true
can you imagine big tech refuses to put
anything in
they took the new york post down for two
weeks
because they they won't let anyone write
if you put out a little tweet and say
that biden is corrupt
they will knock out your whole account
nobody's ever seen anything like this
and you notice it is outside of what i
say
it is indeed fading away because you
can't have a scandal if nobody writes
about it
so we have the fake news not writing
about it and you
have the big tech not right so so how
can you have a scandal nobody's talking
about it
nobody's allowed to talk it's called
suppression we don't have freedom of the
press
we don't have probably haven't had it
for a long time
but we don't have you know they say
freedom of the press the american way we
don't have
we have suppression by the press that's
what it is
what beautiful words i should have done
the speech this way would have been much
more
interesting or whatever no but seriously
we have
suppression by the press this is not
freedom this is the act
the it really is it's the exact opposite
of freedom of the press you know if you
think about it
every corrupt force in american life
that is responsible for
cruel betrayals that hurt our family and
you know all of the people that we love
they're supported by biden and
they donate about you know i could have
been a much bigger fundraiser than him
but i didn't want to call every head of
a wall street firm every head of
the oil companies that we've made rich
anyway i did a great job we're energy
independent that's not so bad
first time the failed establishment that
started the
disasters foreign wars they support
sleepy joe biden because they get
anything they want
and he took in 300 million dollars last
month you think he made any deals no i
don't think so
the career politicians that offshored
your industries
and decimated your factories they
support sleepy joe
the open borders lobbyists that killed
our fellow citizens with illegal drugs
gangs and crimes
the people that wanted to stop the wall
even though it works it's almost
finished by the way
but the people that wanted to stop it
even the though they knew
full well it worked remember they said
no no
we don't want a wall walls are obsolete
we want drones
drones okay good drones flying to watch
the people pour into our country
they want drones let's have drones the
far left democrats that ruined our
public schools depleted our inner cities
defunded our police and demeaned your
sacred faith and values they support
sleepy joe
and you can't even go to your churches
you can't even go to your church
and your governor of north carolina
you've got to
open up your state
you got to get your governor i hope
you're going to vote for dan
but you got to get your state open don't
worry about it on november 4th they'll
announce your state is open
[Music]
on november 4th north carolina will be
opened on november 4th
the anti right after the election
the entire because they want us to look
bad they don't care about people they
want us to look bad they want to try and
steal an election
the anti-american radicals defaming our
noble history our heritage our heroes
they support sleepy jail antifa
and the riders and looters and marxists
and left-wing extremists
they all support joe biden they always
like to blame it on the right do you
ever notice these were
right-wing and uh it's very rare it's
where it's you get bad on every side but
they always like to blame the right it
always starts off with the right the
right
this election comes down to a simple
choice
do you want to be ruled by the arrogant
corrupt ruthless and selfless political
class
or do you want to be governed by the
american people themselves
you want to be represented by a career
politician who hates you
or by an outsider who will defend you
like you have never been
defended before
[Applause]
i didn't need this job i had a very nice
laugh but i love what we're doing for
our country
nobody's done so much nobody no
administration and you know i never even
had a challenge on this
from the fake news you know normally if
you say something slightly off they make
a big deal
no administration president
has done more in the first three and a
half years than we have
our military we rebuilt our tax cuts
our regulation cuts
[Applause]
space force just a thing like space wars
i never even talked about space force
right during the campaign
i did more than i actually talked about
during the campaign
thank you thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
thank you thank you
i thought this was this small little
cute area
you know this was this small little cute
area when i came in i'm watching fox and
a gentleman an anchor said
they have a small crowd of about two
thousand two
thousand five hundred well
i knew i knew you know it's it's an
incredible thing this is a lot more than
that this is a lot of people just a lot
more than we
i wanted to be here because it's an
important
i mean my granddaughter is named
carolina you know that
and we'll give south carolina some
credit too you know they've been with us
is that okay i want to get your
permission
no we'll give south carolina south
carolina is great
they're great people too a vote for
biden is a vote to hand the
keys to government over to people who
despise you and who want to rob your
children of their american dream
that's what they're doing a vote for
biden is a vote to give control of
government over to the globalists
communists socialists the wealthy
liberal hypocrites who want to silence
censor cancel and punish you
if you want your children to be safe and
remember this
against this i'll put it very simply
against the second amendment
right if you're pro-life you can forget
about
it you know that right tremendous
support
we have we have did you see these people
in california they have
lines of hundreds of miles of cars and
tractors and iowa
and votes five or six thousand votes in
lakes and ocean
with the flags
if you want your values to be respected
if you want to be
treated with honor and dignity and
respect
then i am asking for you to go out
tomorrow or sooner but i don't know you
tend to like to go on election day right
we all do
[Applause]
and vote is going to be the most
important election in my opinion
in the history of our country i never
thought i was going to say it if you
would have told me i was going to say
that four years ago i would have said
you're crazy but it's the most important
because i've always said
we will never be a socialist nation
[Music]
[Applause]
and we well and remember what i said
four years ago i said i am your voice
and we will
make america great again and that's what
we're doing
[Applause]
and if we didn't get hit by the china
plague now we're building it up again
and we're doing it at record clip in
record numbers and
at a much faster pace than any other
country in the world
but we got hit by the plague from china
and we will never forget it
with god as my witness i will never let
you down
for the last four years the depraved
swamp has tried everything to stop me
because they know i don't answer to them
i answer to you
together we will defeat the corrupt
establishment
we will dethrone the failed political
class
and we will drain the washington swamp
[Applause]
and we will save the american dream
[Music]
this election is also a choice between a
deadly biden lockdown he wants to have
you locked down
i don't even know if he knows i'm into
beyond they ask him a question i don't i
don't think he has a clue you can
vote whoever you want but i don't think
he has a clue you know it
the media knows it the media laughs
behind his back and then they say
he did brilliantly today no he didn't do
brilliantly he can't do
he didn't do brilliantly in his prime
and he's not in his prime anymore
or a safe vaccine that ends the pandemic
and we're doing very well with the
vaccines they'll be distributed very
soon
we will mass distribute the vaccine in
just a few short weeks
it will quickly eradicate the virus and
wipe out the china plague once and for
all
joe biden is promising to delay the
vaccine and turn america into a prison
state
looking again that's more kamala you
know remember when they said
this is the harris biden administration
right
i never did that with mike and you know
what mike pence never came to you he
said do you mind if i put my name first
every once in a while
no because and by the way he's been a
great vice president
some people say it was a perfect
combination it was he's a great guy
he loves he's going to be in your state
a little while
locking you in your home while letting
far left rioters roam free
the biden lockdown will mean no school
no graduations no weddings no
thanksgiving
no easter no christmas no fourth of july
and no future
for america's youth other than that it's
fine i think it's just
if you want a vaccine to kill the virus
a job to support your family and freedom
to
live your life then you go and cast
your ballot for president trump
and if you remember the catastrophe joe
biden is telling us how to run things
right this guy never ran a thing
successfully he was said horrible things
about him when he was in the
administration obama didn't even want to
endorse him he wouldn't endorse him
even after we won obama said this is no
way
how long did it take him after he won it
took forever obama couldn't believe it i
don't think obama is much better you
want to know the truth
joe biden personally ran the swine flu
right the swine flu
h1n1 which he can never remember he
never says it
he says it goes n1h1 i said don't
he failed horribly and he was a
laughingstock all over washington they
were laughing at him and his own chief
of staff
said he was absolutely terrible they had
a terrible they did a terrible job
now he's telling us how to do it i
should have closed earlier there's only
one problem he's on record all over the
place
knocking me two and a half months later
for closing too soon
and closing it all he said don't close
he's xenophobic
you know xenophobic i didn't like people
from china is what he's saying it's so
wrong
i think they're incredible people i do i
think they're incredible people
but they he said xenophobic and then he
runs for offices he should have closed
earlier
and you know what the press never covers
that they just you can't get
the only time i get it covered is if i
happen to be on live television i'll say
it again and again
and when i do say it they try and turn
it off let's go to a commercial break
right now i think i know what's coming
these are really bad people
secretary of defense robert gates said
that biden has been wrong
on every actually or nearly every
major foreign policy and national
security
issue over the past four decades he had
no respect for him whatsoever
i'm sure he endorsed him because he's
probably looking for something like
everybody else but
i don't think any of them are going to
get anything because i think we're going
to have one of the greatest victories
tomorrow
but you don't have to take my word for
what a disaster joe
biden is because it's the great state of
north carolina i spent a fortune see
this see the board
i spent a lot of money on the board so
let's just take a look at uh
a little roll let's roll up please have
you taken
a cognitive no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program if you
take a test where you're taking cocaine
or not what do you think huh
are you a joke by the way it's my little
sister valerie
and i'm jill's husband oh no oh you
switched on me
this is my wife this is my sister they
switched on me
but i tell her if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump and you ain't black there is not a
single solitary region in the world
why why as i said we shouldn't be in a
position
that everybody that's my wife jill hey
jilly i'm jill's husband actually
and cornpop was a bad dude and he ran a
bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things had changed
play the radio make sure the television
excuse me
make sure you have the record player on
at night
the phone make sure the kids hear words
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the
you know the thing because if you could
take care
if you were a quartermaster you can sure
in health take care of
running a you know department store uh
thing
in the second floor of the ladies
department you know i mean
well i'm sick and tired of smart guys
you know the rapidly rising uh um
uh in with uh
with uh i don't know uh
mendo caucus no you haven't you're a
lion dog faced pony soldier
why do i attack sanders
you're getting nervous man what kind of
country we're going to be
four more years of george georgia he
is going to find ourselves in a position
where if
trump gets elected we're going to be
we're going to be in a different world
you know we have to come together that's
why i'm running
i'm running as a proud democrat for the
senate and by the way you know i sit on
the stand
and it gets hot i got a lot of i got
hairy legs that turn
that that that that that that turn uh
um blonde in the sun and the kids used
to come up and reach into the pool
and rub my leg down so it was trained
and then watched the hair
come back up again they'd look at it so
i learned about roaches i learned about
kids jumping on my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
barack and i think it's a right
for people that bad at care i'll lead an
effective strategy to mobilize
true international pressure
[Applause]
don't do it don't do it don't do it to
yourselves
our country has such potential you can't
do that to our country
he's not mentally equipped he just isn't
to be your president he's not equipped
to be your president
and i say it you know i say it because
he's not a nice person
never was a nice person but he was never
a smart person he was a touchy feely
person
you know hail and hearty but not nice
but this is not a man that
25 years ago was not equipped to be your
president and he ran many times
numerous times we called him one percent
joe
think of it and now he's working on
about 50
and he ends up winning their nomination
because of elizabeth warren elizabeth
warren gave him the number
all she had to do was drop out and he
would have lost on super
i mean then we would have had crazy
bernie say you know what the hell
but at least bernie you know they had a
great energetic base it's uh
small base but energetic but this is not
a man that should be your president
we have tremendous potential our country
has tremendous potential
and we can't blow it we can't blow it
[Applause]
because there's no way to describe that
and and that's like
one percent we could keep you out here
all day
much of it happened yesterday and the
day before yesterday oh he had some
beauties yesterday
but we can't do this and you know what's
going to happen kamala
will be put in that position very
quickly
and she's more liberal than crazy bernie
she's more liberal
in fact she makes him look like a strict
conservative
joining us today are some incredible
people incredible friends and warriors
and i want to tell you i just looked at
a poll and he's up in the poll
senator tom tillers he's up he's up
that's great i'm good i'm very happy
with that that's we got to get him and
he's a good man
good man and your wife was great the
other night we had a oh good
we had a great rally the other night and
it was you were well represented let me
tell you
very well congratulations well let's
save that for tomorrow or the next day
or as the supreme court would say
sometime into the future
what a ruling what a ruling what a
horrible
thing that they've done you know that
puts our country in danger
do you know what can happen during that
long period of time pennsylvania
the long period of time do you know what
can happen number one cheating can
happen like you've never seen
this is their dream and they are they
are known for it you know the
philadelphia area is known for
but what can happen during that long
period of time is
just a disgrace get your ballots in and
have them in long before the third
and have them counted before the third
and and
have an election where we can say to the
world that we know who won
and we know who lost our supreme court
i'm just i'm just so tired of some of
these horrible
political decisions that are being made
it's a shame
it's a shame and
you know i won't get into it too much
but
i'm going to start getting into it
because they're hurting our country
very badly very good
representative warrior david
rouser rouser david
david rouser david thank you you're
doing a great job
appreciate it uh congress we have a
friend over there
richard hudson where's richard richard
richard hudson congressman
another great guy great guy he's done a
fantastic job and a friend of mine
and somebody that's done an incredible
job also in congress
dan bishop thanks stan
thank you ben
doing a good job he came in you know he
came in through the
the system he won a race that was a
tough race right we worked together on
it and
he had no choke in him he started off a
little behind to put it nicely and he
ended up winning
and he won solid and how are you doing
on this one good i don't have to help
you as much
ah he's going to win he's going to win
he should win he's a great congressman
all of them all three thank you very
much fellas
a man that hopefully you're gonna
recognize for
i guess he doesn't have the funds that
the other one has he's you know
i see commercials all the time for your
governor that has you
in a total lockdown but dan forrest
would be
a phenomenal governor a phenomenal
governor
he would be you could have a surprise
then
that could be a big beautiful gift to
north carolina
[Music]
there you go that's not bad hey dan
that's not bad huh
beautiful that's
hey dan that's a very impressive uh
applause you got i have to be honest
don't kid yourself that is like a poll
you know it's like a poll except instead
of interviewing 73 people they have
thousands of people here
[Applause]
much more than the 2000 well he's got a
nice
2 000 people and i don't think so
well last night in miami you want to see
a crowd you couldn't even see the end of
it i've never seen anything like that
there's such spirit i've never seen
spirit like this and north carolina gop
chair somebody doing an incredible job
if we win tomorrow
by the way if we don't win tomorrow
they'll say
how's michael watley doing i say not
good at all he didn't do a good job
michael watley are we doing okay michael
yes
get out get out the vote mike get him
out
get out the vote thanks michael and you
are doing a good job i also want to
recognize
medal of honor recipient command
sergeant major
bob patterson where's bob
where's bob where
whoa he looks good he looks good
wow your husband
oh that's a good looking couple
wow
that's some uh incredible honor
that's some incredible honor i'll tell
you what
there is no greater honor and uh are you
proud of your husband
but he's proud of you too oh oh she's
proud of trump look at that
thank you i knew i liked her i knew i
liked her
thank you both very much great honor
that's the highest
honor you can get former prisoner of war
and
vietnam veteran captain ken wells
a real a real hero where
[Applause]
a real hero thank you thank you
real tough one look at him he's tough
he's a tough looking
he's a tough looking guy thank you thank
you very much beautiful
you look great thank you these are great
people
and world war ii hero and d-day veteran
very very brave they say harold frank
hi harold
[Applause]
you're looking good thank you harold
thank
[Music]
he said he's a brave one thank you
howard you're looking good
these guys look good i don't know they
go through all that they come out they
look better than all of us i don't know
something about the war something about
brave people right
military spouse and don't ever
underestimate that is
where it all begins somebody who's
incredible donna dotson donna where's
donna thank you donna
thank you very much
thank you donna great to have you thank
you very much and retired sergeant major
karen
de la vega karen thank you
thank you thank you karen
great people thank you all for your
extraordinary service and it's an honor
to have you with us really is thank you
very much
for 47 years joe biden viciously
repeatedly attacked black americans
he decimated the black middle class
and called young black men super
predators
to every black american vote for trump
this is your one and only chance to show
sleepy joe biden what you think of his
decision to attack you to insult you to
jail you
and to betray you i am fighting for you
and got criminal justice reform prison
reform
opportunity zones with tim scott
and funding for historically black
colleges
and universities i got it done nobody
else got it done
and with the exception of and i use the
word possibly
possible exception but i could use it or
maybe i won't i'll keep it a little bit
less controversial
with the exception of abraham lincoln
there's been no
president that's done more for the black
community than donald trump
no president thank you very much thank
you
thank you thank you very much
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in u.s history
joe biden has pledged to open borders
he's actually talking about taking down
the wall can you believe it
let's take down the wall let everybody
pour into our country
he wants to take down no he said it i
don't know i i maybe
but he did say let's take down the wall
one of the biggest
projects that we've ever done you know
it's a tremendous project we're up to
over 400 miles we're going to be
finished very soon
over 400 miles
exactly designed to the specifications
of the border patrol who are great
mass amnesty wants to give them free
health care
this is for illegal aliens
and wants to keep deadly sanctuary
cities
your state has a sanctuary city you know
that right you have a sanctuary
right a very big one actually that
doesn't work
very well we believe our cities should
be sanctuaries for law abiding americans
not criminal aliens
the biden harris plan would increase
refugees from terrorist nations
by a staggering 700 percent this has
been a great time
this has been a great no thank you
fellas i'm not interested
i'm keeping radical islamic terrorists
the hell out of our country if i have
your problem
if i have the approval of north carolina
i will
we're going to keep them we invested 2.5
trillion dollars in the u.s military we
have the greatest
equipment greatest people
2.5 trillion you think that was easy to
get from the democrats actually the wall
was even tougher
the wall was tougher we got it do you
notice once i got the wall started got
all the funding won all the court cases
against
the democrats the press never talks
about it anymore
they don't talk about it we had the best
statistics the best
and can you imagine during the pandemic
because you know mexico's
very heavily unfortunately infected and
it was a good thing that we had it up
that's why the numbers are so good
we also passed for our great vets va
choice and va
accountability
[Applause]
nobody thought that could happen we
obliterated
100 percent of the isis caliphate
we kill the leader of isis al baghdadi
is dead
last week i visited fort bragg
where i presented the presidential unit
citation to the special forces team
that achieved that historic victory it
was great
and we are keeping the name fort bragg
you do know that
you agree
they want cancel culture you know we won
two world wars out of fort bragg and we
have other forts and
we're uh we're keeping it uh we won two
world wars out of fort bragg
and now they say let's change the name
let's change the name of fort bragg
we'll pick somebody else uh
do you have any good suggestions no
no no we have to we have to keep we have
to keep
it's our culture it's our heritage so
many victories
so many victories out of fort bragg we
also eliminated the world's top
terrorists
solomani is dead
i recognized the capital of israel and
opened the american embassy in jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights 52 years they
tried together
and instead of endless war in the middle
east we're forging peace
they're lined up to come in
i said how did obama and all of those
that came before him do it they told me
they all use the same method
i said really i'm going to go the
opposite method and it worked very
nicely
no no blood in the sand
no cost three very powerful countries
already signed we have many others
they're standing on line
standing in line and we're bringing our
troops back home our troops are coming
back home
they're coming back down 19 years
is enough they serve as policemen
i said no you have to get your own
police department i'm sorry
a vote for me and the republican party
is a vote for
the american dream
and in conclusion over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower
of the world and we will end our
reliance on china which has already
started
can you imagine biden saying we're not
gonna
we're not gonna end our alliance i mean
can you imagine we are going to end our
reliance on you
hey hey we gave you said a billion and a
half what the hell are you telling me
okay well
i don't know senator i think it would be
tough for him right
no he they wanted 10 million they wanted
10 million a year for his services right
and then you say no i'm not going to
deal with china anymore or i'm going to
be tough on china you know i've taken
out
many many billions of dollars we never
did this in this country not 10 cents
i gave 28 billion dollars from china to
our farmers because they targeted our
farmers 20
28 billion and we had plenty of money
left over
which went into the u.s treasury thank
you
we will hire more police increase
penalties for assaults or law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
with god's help we will defend the right
to life
religious liberty free speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
[Applause]
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength
you know we're the envy of every country
in the world our military now has the
greatest equipment all made in the usa
but
we have the greatest equipment in the
world
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency and lower drug prices
even more we instituted a favored
nation's laws we pay by far the most in
the world
we are going to pay now the least in the
world
and nobody can believe i did it and the
big pharma does not like me too much
they are not so happy with me and we
will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
[Applause]
america will add the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation to land an
astronaut on mars
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our school
[Applause]
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
north carolina
i do and your tobacco growers are in
good shape by the way
please let them know okay you have any
tobacco growers here please
they're in good shape they work hard
they were treated very rough
tomorrow you have the power
to do so much for our country you have
the power to vote
so go out and vote unless you're going
to vote for somebody other than me which
case
citadel you ever hear these politicians
get up and they say you have the power
to vote
and it makes no difference if you vote
for me or my opponent
they're such liars it's it's liars
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers get
your boss grabbed them by the ticket
let's go boys
and get out and vote
[Music]
[Applause]
from greensboro to charlotte from
wilmington to raleigh
from asheville to right here in
fayetteville
fayetteville i love the name
fayetteville we inherit the legacy of
american patriots who gave their blood
sweat and tears
to defend our country and to defend our
freedom
stand on the shoulders of american
heroes who cross the oceans
settled the continent tamed the
wilderness
laid down the railroads raised up the
great great
beautiful skyscrapers won two world wars
defeated fascism and communism and made
america into the single greatest nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet to come you will see that
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people with your help
your devotion and your drive we are
going to keep on
working we are going to keep on fighting
we are going to keep on winning
winning winning
[Applause]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god and
together with the incredible people of
north carolina we have made
america powerful again military
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you north carolina
thank you go out and vote
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm sure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
are you listening to
[Music]
but you've got to know this
one thing no man
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
i felt
take a walk up the street
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow